All right, so that brings us to
temporal difference learning.
So, temporal difference learning,
the algorithm we're going to look at
originally by Sutton,
is called TD Lambda.
This is a little Lambda symbol.
So TD stands for temporal difference.
And what really it's about,
is learning to make predictions
that take place over time.
And so as a concrete example,
a concrete way of looking at this,
we're going to look at how we can
from a sequence of states, state
zero goes to state one, goes to state
two, goes to let's say a final state.
And each time there's a transition,
there's some reward that's
associated with that.
We're going to try to predict
the expected sum of discounted
rewards from that.
>> Okay.
Which is what we're trying to do anyway.
>> Yes, so this is going to be a really
important subroutine for trying to do
reinforcement learning, because we're
going to use the notion that we can
predict future rewards to try to better
choose actions to generate high rewards.
>> Okay, that's fair.
>> All right, so for the kind of
prediction problems that we're going to
be learning with temporal difference
methods, it's helpful to have
a concrete example to kind of
ground out some of these terms.
So, let's take this as a Markov chain.
With states S1, S2, S3, S4,
S5 and SF for the final state.
>> Okay.
>> I've labeled each of
the transitions with the reward
that happens when you make
a transition from that to the next.
And this particular transition out of
S3 actually is a stochastic transition,
with 90% probability going to S4, and
ten percent probability going to S5.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
>> And what we'd like to learn
here is a value function,
a function that maps
the state to some number,
where that number is set to zero for the
final state and for every other state
it's the expected value of the reward
plus the discounted value of the state
that we end up in, averaged across all
the different states we might end up in.
>> Okay that makes sense.
>> Great, okay, good,
then let's have a quiz.
>> [LAUGH]